Oh  you  Oh  I  haha  yes  Oh  Oh  you  Oh  you  you  haha  I'm  Oh  right so I originally wanted to do a  pretty long time lapse pot really scream  3 at other plans and started to like  like crazy right now it's not as bad as  it used to be when I was just recording  but as soon as I would be like busy for  one minute it would frame drop to about  2 to 1 FPS and it was not nice and a  terrible to work with so yeah I just  decided to cut it down here because I  really I just can't work with it anymore  I need to get rid of some files on my  computer I suppose maybe start it up  again and started recording another life  another let's play episode so sorry if  this one was a bit short I'll try to do  longer ones as well but i also want to  focus on the tutorial i'm doing about  bat roller coasters because i want to  focus on more on tutorial wasn't  actually teaching you guys some other  things that I've learned in all these  years as well so see you then